breaking news story uh washington moving
to designate the houthi movement as a
foreign terror group let's talk to
marwan kabalan who's the director
of policy analysis at the arab center
for research and policy studies
he joins us on the phone from doha
marwan good to have you on
so the us says it's now planning to
designate the houthis as a foreign
terror group
why now and how significant is this do
you think
i think it's very significant but we
have been expecting it
also for some time now because this is
part of the maximum pressure the us is
trying to put on iran
and its allies before it leaves office
um
i think this is probably the last chance
that the trump administration has in
order to do that
because we all know that trump will be
out of the white house
by the 20th of this of this month it's
significant because
it might lead to undermining any future
peace efforts because if you designate
someone as a terrorist organization you
won't be able to negotiate anymore with
him
so this is something that the united
nations has been very concerned about
taking into account the peace process
that is going right now between
under the auspices of the united nations
although i mean sometimes we are seeing
that this peace process is not actually
making any progress nevertheless
uh this might be a very uh important
blow to any peace office
i mean led by the united nations in
yemen
this uh this issue of designation as a
foreign terror group is very important
but many people ask the question what
does it actually mean
when the u.s designates persons or
organizations as a foreign terror group
you can't talk to him anymore and the
houthis are ruling
yemen right now although i mean nobody
actually
recognized them as a legitimate
government of yemen but they are very
important party to the conflict in yemen
so if you don't talk to the houthis how
are you going to make peace in yemen
this means actually that there will be
no peace uh
as long as you designate them as a
terrorist organization
and the statement goes on to say iran
has been arming the houthis with
missiles drones
other weapons and continues to
destabilize the region
how much is this a final job at iran
before president trump leaves office
well i mean we all know actually that
iran is arming the houthis and
supporting the houthis we have been
actually we know this for for many years
right now and because of the iranian
support the houthis have been able
actually to
to take over power in in sanaa but on
the other hand as i said earlier
this is not this this is this is going
to be a very
major blow to any peace offers in yemen
you can't actually as you said earlier
talk to al-hoti's anymore now if you
recognize them as a terrorist
organization so
it's very much like you are killing any
attempt towards these in yemen
is is this designation then likely to
prevent un
nor us diplomats from meeting with the
houthis because of course
as you as you pointed out the houthis
are critical to any political resolution
aren't they
it will complicate i have the efforts of
the united nations
uh the united nations will find it
extremely difficult right now
to talk to al-hoti's if they are
designated by the united states
uh as a terrorist organization
by the uh designated by the u.n so we
can't talk to them
but nevertheless that would complicate
things for the u.n uh
everybody is hoping right now that the
by the administration might actually
just just reverse that decision and
may um i mean it might not actually this
decision lasts for that for
a long time yeah that's an important
point you make there my one because i'm
going to ask you you know what will this
mean for joe biden and the new
administration
in washington do they have the option of
supporting it or vacating it or i mean
could they throw it out because perhaps
of the wider humanitarian concerns
absolutely i think biden will be
focusing on yemen as soon as he comes
into office
and i believe most probably they are
going to reverse this decision because
they know very well that they can't
proceed with the peace of us
while they are designating the other
terrorist organization
all right marwan kabalam the director of
policy analysis at the arab center
for research and policy studies thank
you very much for talking to us let's
bring in hussein alba katie
he joins me by phone from the yemeni
capital sanaa he's a pro
houthi journalist hussein what's your
response then to this designation
as a foreign terror group and what does
it mean to you
uh uh um i i was expecting this to
happen
like many many months ago because rosie
here uh
they have an anti a us policy uh in the
region and i expected that the united
states would like that and they will
put them in the terrorist organization
but i do agree with the guest
before that he said this will this
action will
actually undermine uh the peace process
but to be honest
this is actually will be in favor of the
military wing
of uh houthi or anthalada houthi because
for
the last six years the peace process
actually hasn't done
anything uh there is either uh here in
sarah they are blaming
mr griffith the unemployed chairman to
be biased
towards saudi arabia and that he is not
actually
trying to bring peace into yemen and
this is all
and with this latest decision will will
have
actually a bad effect on saudi arabia
because if you are not talking
with the houthi if there is no peace
process this means
that the military uh action will be the
only
answer uh to to lift the blue gate on
yemen and
force saudi arabia to stop the war
so that's why i think this uh decision
actually
it could uh stop the war faster than the
peace process because
then the military wing here in sana'a
will be the one who have the
the upper hand to stop the war and the
blockage against him and by striking the
inside saudi arabia and united arab
emirates yeah and the statement
uh goes on to say that iran has been
arming the houthis with missiles drones
and other weapons and continues to
destabilize the region
how did how do you react to that and is
this really all about maximum pressure
on iran do you think
uh i think if what they say is true
because there is blockade on yemen
actually i don't think that iran can
smoke
anything but if it's let's say it's true
this will have no effect if
on hezbollah or in iran iran has been 30
years
under some kind of blockade i mean
this decision from the united states
they actually only want to serve their
foreign policy but to be honest they are
not going to
so this kind of decision actually will
not have
a single uh political uh or military
effects
on them jose let me ask you one final
question i mean what do you think the
humanitarian
impact of this uh foreign terror
designation will be i mean of course
yemen has suffered
for many years under this conflict
thousands have been have died have been
displaced
there's been cholera there's been famine
starvation what do you think the broader
humanitarian effect
of this designation will be
i think the major effects and all the
effect it will be in the humanitarian
situation uh because uh designation
uh to designate one of the important
group
in yemen or in the conflict uh that's in
yemen as a first organization
this will undermine the peace process
and the peace brothers mean this will
have a bad effect on the uh humanitarian
situation
on yemen but on the other hand uh uh
this will will actually increase
the choice of a military action
uh to stop all that and the only way
to stop this humanitarian situation
yemen and the blue cave and the closure
of port and airport in yemen
is kin uh
military leaders are happy now with this
decision
because they have some kind of conflict
with the political leadership
to deal with saudi arabia that's why i
think this is a huge gift
for them to take uh now uh that that
that that to take the situation and take
the decision
uh to to to uh to to to attack saudi
arabia all right hussein albert katie
thank you very much indeed for talking
to al jazeera thank you